what do you think about the term
starving artist
um I think what I think about it
um I think
every creative
is going to go through adversity
and not have any way to sustain
themselves that's how I think about it
that they a starring artist is
someone that's so passionate about what
they that they they are willing to do
everything they can to
make that art form work
and they're willing to die for it
that's how I can't think of it have you
seen this in yourself oh yeah
um for me
I was 19 years old when I decided when I
heard my own from baseball I decided to
go into music and I worked and I worked
a nine-to-five job really was a nine to
nine to uh 97 job that's what I felt
like to me and then from eight o'clock
to four o'clock and five o'clock in the
morning I'm making music
I'm producing the record writing a song
and figuring out how to engineer to make
the best sound seven days a week my
vacations were all about the music and I
would always fund my music through the
job that I had
so I'm not a starving artist because I
had a job but I killed myself to be as
to be the best I can be in doing it now
I look at
me based off being being really lucky to
have a corporate job that could do that
and had the flexibility for that and I
look at artists that don't have that
capability they don't have the
technology background they don't they're
just not wired that way they just
extremely creative extremely talented
music art wherever it is and they can't
function another way
and
um and they are doing that 16 18 hours a
day
and they're willing to just eat peanuts
just to make a living just to do that
and I think that that's the
yeah that's what a starving artist is
and that's that's the one of the reasons
why I'm I want to fix and you know not
me but personally I want to bring a
community in to help flip that world
upside down so they don't become
Starving Artists and I think those are
the probably the ones that are the ones
that can
Enlighten people
and you said there was a lot of
predatory tactics in the music industry
do you think because you had a day job
you didn't give off the desperation
because a lot of predators they sense
desperation and they usually go after
yeah people that that they know are weak
and that can't fight back you think that
you think that you kind of were able to
deflect some of that because you had
this job
no I had I had the that's I was
desperate to you know because you go so
much you know I mean you I'm working
like crazy on it
um it's no I had the same feeling that
of desperation and I signed bad
contracts too
and I remember myself just yelling on
the phone
you know to get myself out of the
contract because they screwed me and
um
and then eventually I did get out of it
you know luckily but it's uh but I've
been screwed so many times in the music
industry so because because I was an
idiot
taking on something that I because I was
desperate for
so so even though you had a uh you were
able to pay the rent so to speak you
still got oh yeah there were still
sharks okay there were so many shocks
for that yeah so you decided to leave
and put a pause put on pause that's
right put on pause yeah okay so it's on
pause and do you think that the most
talented artists
are the most successful
um
well let's define success
um success to me is being happy and and
in what you're doing
you know if the artist is living in the
garage you know
um and and but still happy where they're
living I would look that as a success
for artists you know
um and so
um so to me that that's a that's really
just a uh it's success is a personal
question
why do you think so many artists
struggle
financially despite their talent
the first of all I think the medium is
is the medium right it's the you know
the music the films it's anything that's
creative
outside people don't value it
like that even though they use it every
day right they you know from anything
they see visually to the things that
they listen to they listen to the the
music that helps them program their
thing or help to do their homework but
they don't want to pay for it and so if
the consumers don't pay for it that
means that
um the artists are not going to be as
valued as they should be
but
but that's why they call it a business
you know it's not just music it's not
just filmed it is a film business it is
a music business and most artists have
no interest in business
at all
who wants to actually go into QuickBooks
or spreadsheets
and make updates to to a client uh it's
a CRM system you know who wants to do
that nobody wants to do it they want to
go in there make music be emotional
about it tell a story go to sleep you
know and that's what they want to do for
a living
um I get it I was that guy too but but
if you want to survive in the Financial
world and that's another game
then you gotta be good at business if
you're not good at it then I don't know
what to tell you you know I think that's
it goes hand in hand if you want to
survive in that game financially
plus I think too it helps someone not be
taken advantage of
if they just blindly turned everything
over to someone I've heard horror
stories of all sorts of stuff happening
where they weren't aware but if you ask
questions and you are aware of sort of
accounting and different things and yes
you must likely yes I think that you'll
be less taking advantage of however
business people to business people take
advantage of each other too and so it's
it's a it's not about understanding
about the business it's about Leverage
like if you're an artist that has the
hit song or hit film where it is and
then you get all these Distributors the
ages wanted to go after you
they're they're in advantage and they
could take advantage of the business
people because of the because of that
you know what I'm saying
and so it's um and so I think that it's
so it's so yeah being taken advantage is
all about leverage it's not about
knowing more business on what what it is
you know if you're a great artist if
you're in demand if you're like Whitney
Houston
right or you're like Mariah Carey or
Ariana Grande they don't need to know
anything about business but they could
take advantage of the business people
that's how I can look at it because they
got the goods because they're the ones
that are going to make a billion dollars
to these people and those people will be
desperate for those type of artists that
don't come around often
why is it that artists lack business
skills
it's like a oxymoron right it's like the
it's a um
you know it's a complete opposite of
their nature artists is creative there's
a different brain and business is a
different brain
um
for me speaking I I never wanted to
touch a spreadsheet you know or
um even though I'm Asian I actually suck
at math okay and so
um and business is math you know and
it's it's this this negotiations it's
um it's being able to
talk
almost sometimes
non-transparently in order to get a deal
done it's a it's a game it's a war
it's still creative in that sense but
it's not but in in the art in making
musical films you want you know there's
nothing I mean you tell you're writing a
script
you you know you you're you're telling a
story there's no business or it's so
much more fun right you get to be
emotional with it business is business
you know and
um and for my for my experience that
like
um some artists try to be business
people and they just can't be one and
they just don't
they don't practice it enough
do you think all artists deserve to be
paid for their work 100 percent
um I believe that
artists need any great artists
great artist that deserves that that uh
that is recognized for their talents it
should absolutely be doing it for a
living you know there's no reason they
should be
be a painter when they could
you know when they could move a 50 000
people crowd as a musician
there's no reason for that you know
um if you're a filmmaker that could
that that's a you know another Quentin
Tarantino of Storyteller that could
impact the world there's no reason that
we should be should be waiting tables
when they could be changing the world
another way
um
yeah so artists has to get ours the
artist needs to survive and then you
know they need to be able to sustain
themselves so yeah and we want to see
those people people out there right to
do that and inspire people